welcome to this video Christmas video 15
minutes as something more relaxing for
those festive days let's see playing
with our chest without chest from the US
biddable drastic rating difference here
sometimes happens in the 15 minute pool
there are not so many players in for
this time control unfortunately all
right we have the pills defense and he's
um yeah is he chose a real long and that
BTW seven against the the austrian
attack would have for what really sure
why it is called the austrian attack
don't know any austrian player and
associated with with this okay um you
know 16 is a move that comes to mind
this position like this happen is very
rare allowing d5 but i recently saw that
even shock had played this so there's
probably some pointed but nigeria's
strange one if i go eat 6f take see 695
the night is hanging and that's night x
e6 winning the exchange so this is
basically a double attack unless he
plays night df6 covering this night on
g4 and then I could play h3 h3 night h 6
g for stuff like that hmm that's tricky
if i start with nigeria can't stop bad
I can also play h3 and g4 pushing it
back on the on the edge but it's got c5
this is a bit this is business is a lie
and this is annoying and interesting
I'm not so sure that I should really go
from one of the the direct refutation
tries maybe here intending insects they
can play c5 are still the c6
okay i'll fly that i spent already spent
too much time here and then there's this
quick move that's not really critical
that one okay the question is aged 30 mg
for i mean i can i can basically play
that all the time yeah let's prepare
young castles as i'm going to go h3 and
g4 I really like to Castle long him Oh
that's that's a bit shocking this move
why would you give up your yeah strong
piece like the bishop for the night okay
mom I need to recapture yeah that's
really a remarkable louth yeah what this
is this almost winning for white I think
just just too much too much going on
here oh yeah now is his even giving up
the option to break in the center with
c5 breaking breaking up the center and
then click on the default okay hmm yeah
well this is very nice for white but how
do you actually win the game
I like the idea to play a 5 but 95
ourselves not not helping our weight I
ever have a much simpler solution
probably let's yeah I can I can play
that ok g5 this is a longer variation
but a very convincing one yeah attacks
the Nile it only has the square now I do
bishop to be one taking the Queen and
the Queen only has aged five then I
exchange on h5 take f5 and d7 is gone so
I can basically remove but with the
bishops on the D file and win the night
on d 7 he has no real escape here he
could term interesting is this is the
saving the piece yeah well not really I
have firm more than one good move
actually even known queen e four is good
attacking the Queen Esther detect and
hmm I'm just taking the night
the other tuck defense pass defense or
the modern defense with g6g 6 is an
opening where you really cannot afford
much leeway check it so it's also the
kind of opening that a stronger play
always welcomes of the opponent let's
say you're out reading your opponent
quite clearly you always glad if we
place such an opening so almost
guaranteed that you have some space
advantage and control the game yeah he
just gave me just gives me more material
even that what I can take check
yeah this was a bit of a mismatch but
the 15-minute million poor always check
yeah suffers from this slight slight
problem yeah maybe i can i can finish
with a neat made if he takes f4 I can
take fa then meet him it's quite quite
nice check I spoiled sport Jack cannot
really move much only pawns maybe I can
set up them suits on gras effect oh no
come on yeah it won't but he needs to
move the bishop sooner or later and then
I have coogi had made yeah now he needs
to move the bishop and the squinty eyed
made or the King moves and then queen
ever made only those two checkmate yeah
yeah it was a provisional game fun so
it's not played many games so it's got
far lower ratings in five minutes like
1200 new to this server yeah well it
happens and those those time controls um
yeah the problem with those kind of
opening is that you don't stake any
claim in the center which is not um not
a general problem but you need to you
really have a very small margin for
error every misstep can can be very
costly and we look at the game
we see that really quickly ups no that's
too much really quickly he got into
trouble yeah he 6 was tempting but
looking this was the line I was
considering I'm not so sure that this is
great he has this route to get the night
back and actually challenged my piece on
g5 this is of course playable provide
let's say here something like that it's
a playable I'm position of course but I
wasn't sure that this is really yeah
yeah so convincing it's not a bad move
Queenie to strengthening and this this
fields too passive really the move black
wants to play SC high if I'm not sure
that it is playable because of e6 this
was my idea anyway ah interesting the
computer suggests he takes d4 ed 7
Bishop d7 91 and Queen B 6 with some
compensation for the piece yeah this is
some an interesting suggestion it's not
full compensation but it termed give
some practical chances the computers on
plus plus one for white one pawn not too
much yeah that's the interesting defense
much more active and as long yeah I
again c5 as the move but he simply never
plays it yeah well around here it is
very after that black is almost losing I
guess yeah computers it's very
pessimistic now and it gives Queen c6 as
a move that's really a good one to be
honest it blocks the sea porn and this
is the only counter play black as sin
ending I mean this is not bad as well
but Quincy success of a strong move okay
yeah this is this is too passive and
after that it's it's a material win
already the relatively best defense is
Knight takes d5 p.m. and the key line is
that one of course winning the the night
with an overwhelming position yeah I
know you is just check giving away
material so who clean down yeah well
this is a risky opening against the
player that out rates you largely well
probably we will you will lose anyway
but this is quite often not helping a
more solid choice of opening is probably
a better better try alright thanks for
watching and have a nice Christmas Day
of course